[Musique]
vous l'avez sûrement déjà remarqué il ya
plusieurs publications en ce moment sur
internet des publications 100 jeunes
virale qui laisse entendre qu'on peut
soit guérir ou prévenir le corps n'avait
reçu la copie de 19 par le biais de
boissons maison de remèdes maison par
exemple boire de l'eau toutes les 15
minutes
boire des boissons chaudes boire de
l'alcool se gargariser avec de l'eau
salée
tout ça absolument tout ça est faux et
archi faux
ce qui revient le plus souvent dans la
boîte courriel des décrypteurs c'est la
question des boissons chaudes la fausse
croyance laisse croire qu avec des
températures qui accèdent 27 degrés ben
ça tue le virus statut la coved de 19
rien n'est plus faux ce qui est avérée
scientifiquement c'est que la comédie 19
le virus on arrive à tuer mais quand on
atteint des température de 65 degrés et
qu on les maintient pendant plusieurs
minutes
autrement oublier ça ensuite pour ce qui
est de l'alcool effectivement il ya des
formes d'alcool qui peuvent venir à bout
de la coved 19 mai à des concentrations
de 75 % d'alcool
alors ça c'est pas propre à la
consommation humaine
vous l'aurez bien compris morale de
l'histoire il faut s'en remettre aux
recommandations des agences de santé
publique et je me permets de le répéter
c'est important se laver les mains avec
de l'eau et du savon pendant au moins
une vingtaine de secondes éviter de
porter les mains au visage
également je sonne c'est pas mal plus
efficace que toutes ces fausses
croyances qui circulent
[Musique]